Hey Thoughty2 here.
For most of us, when we’re people watching,
the normal thoughts that come into our heads
are “I wonder where they’re going?”
“Is that a couple” “Are they wearing
those clothes for a dare?”
But there are a select few of us whose first
thought, when they spot a face in the crowd,
is “mustard or gravy?”
Human meat, the great forbidden delicacy,
has been eaten throughout history because
of rituals, desperate bids for survival, curiosity
and when Tesco ran out of horse meat.
Cannibalism, or anthropophagy as it’s officially
known, is still occasionally practiced in
places like Indonesian New Guinea, but has
generally been the last resort of those with
no other choice, like when stuck up a mountain,
adrift on the ocean or locked in a KFC.
So where does the law stand on this?
And how about your doctor, how would he feel
about you literally taking your pound of flesh?
Today we find out; can you eat people?
In most parts of the world, there has been
a strong disdain for cannibalism, which you
can see reflected in the myths and folklore
where it’s used an example of truly depraved
behavior, such as in Hansel and Gretel and
stories of the witch Baba Yaga.
In Greek mythology, Tantalus was punished
for boiling up his son, Pelops, and serving
him to the gods.
He was sent to the deepest corner of the underworld
and his fitting castigation was that when
he was hungry and grasped for a grape, it
was always just too high.
And the water below him also shrunk away whenever
he tried to quench his thirst.
This is where we get the word “tantalizing”;
something that is just out of reach.
For those tribes that did indulge in the practice
of cannibalism, it was either to absorb the
power of those they had killed, such as the
strength of rival warriors, or it was a process
of grieving and would be done to the bodies
of friends and family members.
I’m assuming the flowers were used as some
sort of side salad.
Many sieges throughout history, such as Jerusalem
in 70AD and the First Crusades, have reports
of soldiers and civilians having to cannibalize
the fallen when all other supplies were exhausted.
In World War 2, during the 872-day assault
on Leningrad, now St Petersburg, the police
had to form an anti-cannibalism division,
which was only slightly more popular than
traffic duty.
Well, would you want to give a ticket to a
tank?
Of course, human beings are not alone in this
merry sport, there are plenty of animal species
who will happily chew their way through the
odd cousin, such as the usually vegetarian
hippos who were found chomping on a decaying
hippo carcasses during a difficult year.
But for some species, especially at the early
stage of development, cannibalism is programmed
to kick in depending on the environment, as
a form of species preservation.
When tiger salamanders are born, if there’s
not too many larvae then they all develop
nice and friendly and remember to buy each
other socks for Christmas.
But at some point, when it all gets a bit
overcrowded, then a random selection start
growing with a broader head and triple length
teeth and, rather than chasing the normal
dinner of aquatic invertebrates, they devour
the smaller salamanders who are the most nutritious
available meal.
It’s cannibal coding to make sure that at
least some of the offspring survive when there’s
not enough food to go round.
It’s a bit like a mother of five throwing
two cheeseburgers into the kitchen and then
locking all the doors.
Ignore the screaming; it’s for their own
good.
And if you think that’s mean of mum, well
nature has its own revenge planned there.
If you didn’t think spiders were already
awful enough, the crab spider mother lays
extra unfertilized eggs for her young to eat
but, greedy-sideways-walking-sticky-string-spewing-agents-of-satan
that they are, it’s not enough and they
also eat their own mother over a few weeks.
Honestly, this generation, no respect.
This is called Matriphagy, which means “mother-eating”
and… well, you just go ahead and make your
own joke.
So, back to humans.
Unlike these salamanders and spider, us humans
are clearly not genetically designed to eat
our own flesh so; is it safe?
In the 1930s, Australian gold prospectors
discovered there was a huge population of
native people living in the highlands of Papa
New Guinea, an area we had thought to be relatively
empty before then.
Over the next few decades, as researchers
began to spend time with these people, they
found there was a very mysterious disease
that was killing around 200 a year in the
eleven thousand strong Fore tribe.
It was known as Kuru, which meant “trembling”,
since sufferers would quickly lose control
over their limbs, as well as their emotions.
Once it took hold, it took about a year before
they were completely incapacitated.
The obvious suspicion was that it was some
rare genetic condition that had been passed
down within the small DNA pool of the tribe.
But as they tracked the victims, they realized
that there was a correlation with social groups
but not with genetic ones, so there must be
an environmental reason.
And of course you have already guessed what
it was.
The Fore believed it was better that they
ate their dead than leave it as food for the
worms so they whipped up a cranial stew of
brain, fern and bamboo, while the rest of
the body was roasted over the fire.
It’s thought that at some point, one of
the Fore must have developed CJD, Creutzfeldt-Jakob
Disease, the human form of mad cow disease,
and then that was spread through the tribe,
not as a virus or bacteria but by eating the
brain prions, which is a messed up kind of
protein, which could take decades to take
hold and begin the mysterious Kuru.
So, from a doctor’s point of view, eating
humans is probably up there with smoking,
drinking super-sized sodas and that thing
you do when the door’s closed; it makes
you go blind apparently.
Doctors is one thing but what about lawyers?
Do they enjoy the taste of human…
I mean… is it, from a legal perspective,
okay to consume another person?
Obviously, killing people is off the table,
that is almost certainly illegal.
But can you take a nibble on a corpse if you
come across it in the forest?
And what about in the case of desperation?
Much of the ruling that exists is built around
a law school classic called Regina versus
Dudley and Stephens from 1884, with Regina
being Queen Victoria, at this point.
A ship called the Mignonette (“Min-yon-ay”)
was sailing from Southampton to Sydney when
it hit a gale near the Cape of Good Hope and
they had to abandon ship, ending up in a lifeboat
with just some navigation equipment and two
tins of turnips.
There were 4 people in total, the captain
Tom Dudley, two sailors Edwin Stephens and
Edmund Brooks, and a 17 year old cabin boy
named Richard Parker.
After two days, they ate the first tin of
turnips.
I’m sure it was delicious.
A couple of days later they managed to kill
a turtle and this, along with the other turnip
tin, let them survive to almost 2 weeks at
sea.
Richard Parker fell very ill and slipped into
a probable coma.
After much discussion and almost 20 days in
the life boat, Dudley pushed his penknife
into the boy’s neck, while Stephens held
his legs.
Both claimed Brooks had agreed, but he denied
this.
They all ate the dead boy and four or five
days later they were rescued.
They told the truth when brought back to England
and a major case ensued, with Brooks turning
state’s witness.
Both Dudley and Stephens were found guilty
of murder and sentenced to death, although
they were eventually released after 6 months
in prison, thanks to the Home Secretary, William
Harcourt.
So killing for food in case of emergency is
not okay, but what about cannibalism without
the killing part?
Canadian artist Rick Gibson, obviously having
run out of paint and canvasses, decided to
eat the flesh of another person in public,
in 1988.
He ate a canape made of donated tonsils in
London and the UK has no specific law against
it.
The next year, he set the bar even lower when
he ate a human testicle.
When he tried the same thing in Vancouver,
they confiscated his snack and charged him
with “publicly exhibiting a disgusting object”
but the case was dropped and, having waited
almost 2 months, he hungrily finished his
lunch on the courthouse steps, after the verdict.
The media went nuts…
I mean, they had a ball…oh never mind.
All in all, it’s a good thing the social
taboo and medical dangers have kept us from
snacking on our friends and family.
But, to keep temptation at a minimum, make
sure you never sit too near the fire and maybe
rethink that bacon and maple syrup deodorant,
you’re just asking for trouble.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.